4 de diciembre de 2022 10 15 de la noche
William Bonilla de 15 años acaba de ser
asesinado tras recibir un disparo en la
espalda
estamos en Madrid en el barrio de Villa
verde un suburbio popular donde en
cuestión de meses dos jóvenes perdieron
la vida Víctimas de ajuste de cuentas
entre bandas rivales Javier cuenca es el
representante de los habitantes del
barrio todavía está conmocionado
como veis es un chico muy joven es
prácticamente un niño y lo que menos
esperas Es que con esa edad tenga un
final de su vida tan violento no era un
chico normal del barrio estudiante con
un montón de amigos
desde los años 2000 en la capital
española se han constituido varias
bandas siguiendo el modelo sudamericano
sus miembros suelen ser jóvenes y se
calcula que serían alrededor de 800 cada
vez a más violentos sus enfrentamientos
causaron cinco muertes el año pasado en
el barrio de Atocha en el centro de
Madrid este pastor dirige un programa de
reinserción para los pocos jóvenes que
tratan de liberarse del control de estas
bandas Bueno chicos cada bolsa vamos a
poner
una de melocotón
uno de aceite dos jóvenes a los que
llamaremos Jessica y Arturo hacen parte
de este programa estos alimentos serán
distribuidas a familias que están en una
situación de vulnerabilidad tenemos
entre siete y cinco Siete jóvenes que
están haciendo parte de este trabajo
solidario todavía tienen miedo de dar su
testimonio con el rostro descubierto
fueron amenazados y acosados durante más
de un año después de haberse salido de
su banda la iglesia fue el único Refugio
que pudieron encontrar
las bandas juveniles la banda latinas
tienen un respeto muy grande por por las
iglesias porque las iglesias tienen un
valor o la función de ayudar justamente
a las personas más vulnerables que es
donde la mayoría de ellos se encuentra
donde sus propias familias se encuentran
[Música]
víctima de un padre maltratador cuando
era adolescente Arturo se unió a los
Latin Kings una de las bandas más
poderosas de Madrid dirigió hasta 34
jóvenes y ascendió poco a poco en la
escala durante 15 años una época con
muchas consecuencias que le costó más de
cinco años de cárcel
lo primero que me hicieron fue una
prueba había un chiquito una banda
contrariado le dieron un blog que es
marihuana con cocaína a la prohibir me
dijeron cuando
el cuchillo porque de esa manera no
resucita no tiene más oportunidad
Jessica se enfrentó cara a cara con la
muerte golpeada por su pareja que
ocupaba un alto Rango en una banda rival
pensó que no sobreviviría
s
te conocen Entonces cómo vas a salir de
allí sin ninguna protección intente
suicidarme cinco veces porque yo no
sabía Cómo enfrentar yo no no me
perdonaba a mí misma evitar que los
jóvenes se unan a estas bandas es el
trabajo de Juan este educador recorre
desde hace 12 años el barrio de Ciudad
lineal la zona es particularmente
sensible tres de las cuatro bandas
principales están presentes aquí y se
enfrentan para extender su territorio
aquí la verdad que empieza todo los
jóvenes lo que es la calle y los parques
su hábitat natural donde se relaciona y
se socializan normalmente los chicos se
acercan a las bandas vale porque al
final es verdad que siempre están en un
sitio dan apoyo y al final los chicos
quieren quieren acabar entrar para
luchar contra este fenómeno desde hace
más de 10 años su asociación lleva a
cabo talleres de prevención Hola hola
qué tal hoy Oscar dirige una discusión
con adolescentes que tienen entre 15 y
18 años es una de las franjas de edad
más vulnerables Hola alguna banda ha
intentado que vayáis con ellos se os ha
acercado tú te vas con gente de bandas
tú también
una persona que no que era de moda me
dijo como Ah si quieres te podemos dar
protección si te podemos enseñar más o
menos el movimiento y yo no no no no no
No yo lo pensé una vez por falta de
dinero a las chicas sobre todo las usan
para guardar armas y drogas
aquí me siento mal a pesar del trabajo
de las asociaciones las promesas de
estas bandas seducen cada vez a más
adolescentes el año pasado la policía
efectuó alrededor de 1.500 arrestos
relacionados con estas bandas de jóvenes
delincuentes